hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute das spiel werde ich schon mal
immer noch wie das heißt infinite ihr
weil wir sind ein reh oder hirsch oder
wurde war ziel des spiels ist es auf
jeden fall ohr ist noch okay irgendwie
was ist das sie rief exchange program
abraham ist durch gespielt mama wir sind
wieder auf rasen
so könnt ihr bitte wecke was ist das
hier das ist das also wir müssen bei dem
spiel eigentlich hier durchlaufen und
über die straße rüberkommen das ändert
ein eigentlich so ein bisschen an was
macht dieses auto da vorne
die leitplanke kommen wir aber leben
ich habe gerade in den power sprung
gemacht aber ich weiß nicht mehr wie
alter das sieht aussetzen doch als wenn
die das revier irgendwie auf drogen wäre
man ok freunde
ich dachte gerade das spiel nein das
ressort und ich habe gedacht als ich
dieses spiel gesehen habe dass es so ist
wie
rate ich hab das spiel auf dem handy was
ich meine ich habe davon sogar schon mal
ein video hochgeladen von dem spiel was
mir gerade einfällt vom namen und zwar
heißt es crociere wenn ihr das cross
road video von mir noch nicht gesehen ob
das schon so alt dass verleger ich euch
hier
da könnt ihr gleich drauf klicken oder
so das hier ist crosswater muss man
quasi einfach so rüber springen und wenn
man gegen so ein laster springt dann
stirbt man halt aber man muss quasi auf
die andere seite kommen hier allerdings
ist es so dass es keine andere seite
gibt man schaut euch das mal an ich
hüpfe mit dem revier über buch wir
abnicker sein lkw um
aber klar direkt in mich rein was ist
denn das einst spiel okay ich zeig euch
wenn ich hier nämlich immer weiter durch
fahren da ich schon wieder von übelster
crash passiert man kann hier nicht
weiter da ist einfach wald endlich weiß
nicht ob wir irgendwie crash verrichten
eingesperrt ich bin ein gesperrt
es ist in ordnung finde dierig meine wir
müssen so wie ich das jetzt verstanden
habe einfach so stimmt halt einfach ich
glaube das ziel des spiels ist dass wir
ein möglichst großes vor erreichen um
letztendlich eine möglichst brüssel fort
zu erreichen ja das ist sehr klug luca
ich denke dass wir so nahtod erfahrungen
machen müssen mit den fahrern also wir
sind als dreh auf der fahrbahn und die
weichen dann irgendwann aus kommt dabei
eine ausnahme am netz punkte bekommen er
hierbei ich jetzt gleich hoffentlich
auch noch aus der städter natürlich rein
hier vorne sind überall der held fassen
vom iran jetzt pro juli was geht denn
hier ab wow
schild junge das liegt mir einfach über
mich drüber was geht denn kann ich nicht
im never ending party in jahren leitet
weil die story and determined persia
terry ahn um 24.500 punkte ich weiß
nicht ob das gut oder schlecht ist aber
die zahlen sind auf jeden fall ein
blinken und dass die nicht mal als
positiv 24.500 punkte müssen wir noch
knacken alter dieses spiel macht
tatsächlich spaß und es ist kostenlos
also es ganz cool das stets war man wenn
man sich das downloaden will dass man
geld bezahlen soll aber muss man nicht
unbedingt also dass
was will der hase der hase das ist viel
zu gefährlich für dich hier hase kommt
ich hab's dir gesagt hase aber du
wolltest ja nicht hören man kann sich
beim download nämlich aussuchen ob man
dem entwickler spenden möchte oder nicht
also so ähnlich wie bei keine ahnung ich
kenne keinen vergleichbaren service aber
wir konzentrieren uns wieder aufs spiel
und zwar müssen wir irgendwie über diese
hatte die punkte werden einfach und ob
gezielt mit den lkw mit oh mein gott
kommen du auch noch ein paar du auch
noch ein
ich bin immer wieder überwältigt davon
wie viel brutalität in einem spiel sein
kann ich weiß doch gar nicht was bringt
es wenig space drücke dann fällt einfach
alles an zu leuchten was bringt das was
geht dann irgendwas kommen dann mehr
autos gibt es am meer crashes irgendwas
passiert da irgendwas passiert auf da
liegt seinen knochen bestehen so
hyperaktiv ich bin das reduziert wir
gehen auf die 100000 zu das ist mal das
ziel am krassesten sind echt diese
laster die drifte markt komplett von der
spur ab wo er hin zu verhindern lassen
er ist verschwunden
jungs was geht hier ab alter was ist
denn hier schon wieder fast allein hasen
nein ihr bleibt dahinter
hier kommt nicht mit auf die straße das
ist viel zu gefährlich für euch kleinen
süßen häschen ein hase nein nicht mit
auf die straße ihr sollte hinten bleiben
geht wieder zurück als er dieser habe
für dumme feature geht doch einfach
zurück in euer scheiß ding hier okay die
hasen lass mich nicht wieder daraus okay
wenn ihr unbedingt wollt dann könnt ihr
mit auf die strecke gekommen jetzt wenig
spannendes hier sind unter tv einen hase
ist gerade gestorben aber wir haben
immer noch die koppel mädchen denn du
bist nicht so blöd und stift
das leben für mich als hirsch macht
keinen sinn mehr ich entschuldige mich
an dieser stelle an alle hasen liebhaber
und hasen die ich hiermit gerade traurig
gemacht habe wenn euch das video
trotzdem gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen